aha
as i expected
the biochip i'll let you have a peek if
you can help me that is
i am glad you have had change of heart
where can we meet
you come to our chapel in pacifica and
must wait by the altar
fine i can do that
[Music]
[Music]
my body
wow
you are here
so how come placee didn't know about the
biochip you didn't recognize
it in the scans few of our people know
about kompeki tower
but placid is your better
where are we going soon you will see oh
the watcher did not notice the bio
chipping you
strange did you let him scan you
hmm no why it would complicate our work
there's an old subway tunnel no part of
the trans-continental maglev system
when all states were connected like the
net
viewers
we take you into this cyberspace no
better place for you to interact with
your construct
all this means you got your own
synthetic interface
we have our own versions of all we do
not use anything from the city
how do i know i'll come back do i get
some guarantee
you'll be inside our data fortress under
watch
under your watch if you knew what is out
there in this cyberspace
you would not be so choosy
okay hang on i want to know what you
need silverhand for
first we wish to contact all cunningham
we know she and silverhand were close
the relic which arasaka held close
it is our only lead alts cunningham
heard of her oh where
from whom what's your plan to contact
alt
we tried to cut out a unique piece of
silver hands engram from the biochem
alt will know it if something of the
human is left after years beyond the
black wall
she will answer well what you said
nothing about breaking through the black
wall
well now you know
[Music]
connection stop the black wall
what is it exactly i mean i know
you know only what the net watch tell
you
the final bastion against the post-war
ais
the great victory of humanity over chaos
that would be your saturday morning
netwatch propaganda
but the black wall is an ai itself the
boundary condition let nothing pass
through
either way if the ais thought like
people
they would call it a traitor
let's do this
oh
okay what now
foreign
[Music]
where are we this is our bbs
data fortress bridge to the deep net
so what now we can begin
all is ready
we enhance your link to silverhand's
neural network for a short time
to grab the fragment we must find the
data on alt
alt alone this should only take
[Applause]
[Music]
what's happening
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well
[Applause]
spit it out first
[Music]
[Applause]
never even told me half that about all
really any examples i don't know but you
were a couple
and she wrote soul killer but she's dead
[Music]
how the hell is she supposed to help us
now as a ghost she's not
dead managed to escape i saw the body
[Music]
oh fled into the net
when'd you find out when she made
contact
and what'd she say that she was a
captain
but they couldn't hurt and she told me
not to come looking for her
so what did you do got my hands on two
thermonuclear charges
[Music]
and headed back to our soccer tower
little boys think they know where she is
being on the black wall
where nobody can touch her bridget's
prime to go there
break through just to contact alt talk
to him
too much for our little pro
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so did it work yes
we extract the necessary fragment of
silver hands and gun
we are ready now to make contact with
hot first
we must dive deeper
[Music]
none have yet returned
i held up my end of ordeal
if we pass through that wall i want
johnny's psyche
we will not pass through you will take
[ __ ] you might have guessed
never had any intention helping me did
you
it does not matter anymore
you got much
how do i get to the other side
[Music]
alt
johnny
[Music]
you cannot remain here
what the hell is going on they breached
our bbses we have nothing to do with
this
[Music]
it's really you what happened out there
couldn't just take them out that watch
was well prepared this time
gotta be mostly a [ __ ]
damn it i brought that watch here agent
i dealt with must have slipped me a
tractor that led him right in
switch things up on the slide replacing
the voodoo spiders with his
[Applause]
[Music]
we're okay everything's chill
i have recognized your engram code but i
do not know why you are here
so you can pay me back for getting you
out of our subtower
me net runner night city's
ever seen alt this is v
you need to save his
throughout life killing me a construct
on it's worming its way through my
neural system
i see this but why is it my problem
why the [ __ ] isn't it you created soul
kill we handed
[Music]
gonna tell me now this ancient
this should be obvious to you as you
were responsible for her death
your death wasn't johnny's fault
how could you know seeing you in his
memories
it was an accident what you saw was his
subjective view of what happened
a warped account of events he locked
away in his subconscious
and replayed time and again it bears no
resemblance to the truth
i'm not out who are you i
use her data really
you find this icy [ __ ] aspect in there
too
okay i get it you hate johnny's guts but
what about me
i cannot help you
[Music]
what but it's your tech you
[Music]
that advanced enough for you if i could
gain access to mikoshi
it would cease to exist good we can work
with
that we'll get you inside mikoshi and
you'll help the
deal
[Music]
the best runner night city's ever seen
camp busting through koshi on your own
i am a well-known threat there they have
a layer of black ice with my name on it
literally kind of like a custom-made
prison
jumpsuit i refused
what can you do for me exactly everyone
i've met so far said i'm too far gone
by everyone hellman soburo's personal
ass bunch
with the cell killer resident inside
mikoshi
these got a big dusty nomad family
and he'll do anything he'll crack a
window
slip you into makoshi
so we agreed yes
[Music]
before you leave we got to talk
just you and me
[Music]
[Applause]
ah
think of a more fitting end runner [ __ ]
had it coming
[Music]
as much as it tickles me too we got a
delta right
still got mr crumps left
[Music]
[Applause]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
good
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
right
[Music]
really
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[ __ ] that was your tickle sitting rest
don't need your flat knife while we got
a job blah blah blah
[ __ ] our sock blah blah
you really are turning into me
[Music]
might be right we're bickering like a
couple of geezers on a park bench
it's time we let up let a little trusty
cold
[Music]
got no idea where i'm going
that's all i wanted feels like i'm
barely surviving
test of a person's true value death
facing it staring it down you still got
a chance to be
somebody
[Applause]
yeah maybe
what was it like when you died
was on top of the world failure not an
option not a thought
till it happened death feels real now
it's only now i know now
[Music]
that half century to come to terms
makoshi felt i don't know
like sleep lacked awareness had no sense
of passing time
didn't mark it did what they wanted to
me
i just remember cold black void
fear more or was that
your death
let's move back to work
let's do
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you